then I discover that oh I've been doing
what what is wrong the actually
government cannot give you anything but
to take from you they doesn't have
anything to give to a spot to take
foremost hi I'm Michael Moynihan for
recent TV and today we're with adi deo
Thomas the publisher of Africa Liberty
org and a Nigerian libertarian activist
thanks for coming out of there thank you
ah today you are currently on a speaking
tour of Africa titled creating the
pathways to liberty in which you use the
theories for two busty odd to inform the
masses in Africa about free markets tell
us a little bit about that what would
discover from the from the middle point
was that African each tree has been
distorted and it runs down into the
institutions so when we look at books
that are relevant to correct this
distillation that was when we found last
year's bukas relevant and what we do is
we write to universities for techniques
and colleges of education seeking for
collaborations to talk to their student
on individualism property right free
market economy and we move there with
books selected essay on political
economy by pastas and the fangs of
global capitalism 20 minutes about
markets by Tom Palmer the relevant takes
that you can easily explain an African
concept and African context through
African students and the populace do you
find that that that you're having some
measure of success I really need a I get
about 20 30 good emails from student
they want me to come back that old it
now ready broke and DS and DS and we
start setting our competitions based on
those books that issue related to what
and what is really happening and the
solution in Africa and which they are
doing perfectly and that's a good male
that there is no day I wake up and check
my meals they don't see such meals from
student in Africa
in the formation of African Liberty
student organization in all institutions
that we go through it's also a mark to
it because you now see libertarians
student organizations in schools that
we've gone to springing up and carrying
out activities that is in line with our
vision I'm mission this is something of
your own creation this stuff didn't
really exist I assume when you were
student libertarian organizations people
giving you books so how did you become
somebody interested in free market
economics it was a big challenge because
while I was in the university I was the
first place I went to pull technique I
was like any student unionism I talked
to students about what is happening I
challenged authorities so start
discovering bruised I've never come
across just I have an interest in it and
by the time i read i'm able to situate
it to african scenario then i discover
that oh I've been doing what what is
wrong the actually government cannot
give you anything but to take from you
they doesn't have anything to give to a
spot to take from us so that was how it
was there one book that really sort of
transformed the way you were thinking a
single was there a single book that was
the most influential to you that was
fast yet it was basket it was busted
tell us a little bit about the play that
your view you've written in the you're
performing that is a free market
oriented play explain that a little bit
all right theater folk tales stories are
the basis for teaching Africans so when
I came across a books like that i always
want to probably translate it into a
play that was what happened when i read
the adventure of jonathan gullible and
when I finished I start taking it to the
universities and forced University of
jaws are separated in Nigeria it was
used and play in classes later kadu not
several universities and presently a
multi-billion versity is currently using
it at the Masters level just like the
invite people all around politicians and
display to them what and what you happen
as
specially in this present circumstances
where we're trying to go libera when the
government are even saying that well it
is no more easy they are to go libera on
economy and free-market economy on other
issues like that are there yet thanks
for coming appreciate it for reason TV
I'm Michael Moynihan